よろしくお願いします兵庫県知事戦って
ご覧になってましたかはあれについて
ちょっと校長の思うところを伺いたいん
です
けどあれねまず第1に思ったのはね地方
行政に中央が口出したじゃんマスコミの
バカどがあれはいかんよそんなものは許さ
れんよね何が地方の時代や一生懸命連中
そう言っとるやないか反対のことやっとる
やそれとなんでいつもああいう風に
パワハラだパワハラだ言って追い出すんや
できるやつはみんなパワハラするよ自分
だったらちゃんとうまくやるのにうまく
やらんやつばっかりなんだから怒るわね
ちゃんとやれてどうなるよどんなられたら
パワハラだというそこがいかんのや全く
自分は反省せんやろちょうどマスコミ
みたいやねこの教育をこんなに
むちゃくちゃにしちまってさあれマスコミ
ややったのはだから俺はマスゴミっていう
んや自分は全く反省せずに自分と違う意見
を持っとるやつをともかく潰そうとする
やろ思想の自由なんてながら認めんじゃん
自分たちだけ自由であって報道の自由と
言うんやもんねあいつらこれがリベラルや
で言っとることとやっとることは全然違う
よあれもう1ついかんのは維新やったね
維新まで公認しなかったのねあれ反発戦か
い政治家も政党でさえも反マスコミになれ
ないというこれが日本の血管よだから
だんだん窮屈な社会になってきとるじゃね
上司が下のやつを怒ってはいかんて言っ
たらもうおしまいやで
マスコミのせいやないかあれおかしいと
思わん専門家に対して口を出して汗こせと
言ったんやそのおかげで教育がダメになっ
たんや今度の知事のあれもそうやろ今ちり
社会だからねリベラルになるとちくり社会
になるんだちょっとでも自分より飛び出
たら悪いやつだいうことになるからね必死
になって悪いところを探すところが本当に
悪いかどうかは分からん下のやつを怒鳴る
のはええことやないか下にとっても上に
とってもところがあのゴミがそれは
パワハラだしってはいかんしるより褒めろ
褒めて伸ばせできっこないんや今ほら
NHKで坂の上の雲をやっとるやろ柴太郎
のあれん中でほらええ言葉が出てきたわ
兄弟がね1人は隊長で1人は連合艦隊の
公開士やったかなその弟の方が新聞を
読もうとするんやそすと兄の方がそれを
奪い取ってね破っちまうんやそいうことが
自分の意見もまだ作ってないやつが新聞を
読むと外以外の何者でもないって書いて
あるわ意見は自分で作るもんだ今リベラル
で偉そうなこと言っとるやつお前は体罰を
するから消しかららん言ってわめく連中
自分の意見なんか何にもないやないか全部
マスコミの意見をまるまる信用しとるやろ
ところがマスコミというのはトランプの
言う通りや全てフェイクニュース
よ全てやぞどうしてやはね2つに分かれ
とるんだ1つはねインフォメーション何時
何分あそこに家事が起こりましたこれが
インフォメーションやその原因はこうで
こうでここはねインテリジェンスなんや
想像してやっとるニュース見たらみんな
そうやろ事実に解説を加えるやろニュース
を物差しで測っとるんだその物差しが
正しければインフォメーションも
インテリジェンスも正しいよところがその
物差しがリベラルやろリベラル自体が
間違っとるのに間違った物差しで測った
解説インテリジェンス正しいわけない
じゃんだから全てフェイクニュースだ新聞
乗っとるテレビで言っとるそんなものを
読んで自分の意見を作るうちを攻撃して
くる連中見てみ50年前に新聞に乗っとっ
たことやあいつらの言っとることは今度
安倍ま久しぶりに出たわねようわからん
バカみたいな連中が出てきてギャギャ文句
言っとってねあれみんな50年前と同じ
こと言っとるんよ進歩してないのあれらは
進歩せんのだ自分が絶対だと思っとるもん
でどうして自分が絶対だと思っとるんや
新聞と同じこと言っとるからだから
マスコミがバカだと日本中がバカになるん
だ斎藤知事は結構改革をちゃんと進めてい
て公約も90%以上秩序みたいなところが
あったんですけどその辺があんまり報道さ
れてなかったっていうのもマスコミが都合
が悪いから感じなんですかそうですよ
マスコミはね100%悪いいとこはゼロだ
からうちの報道なんか見てごらんこんな
子供がこんな風に治ったとかひこもない
やろイスラのやることは100%悪いと
いう報道や例えばうちの子供が良くなって
きたというのはね顔見たら分かるんやお
化けみたいな顔しったやつが1ヶ月後には
ね明るい顔になるんやそれ見たら良くなっ
とるんだということは分かるやろそれを
報道せんのだ男じゃない精々堂々として
ないイチもつけて相手を落とし入れの
あいつらみんなちんぴらないだから
マスコミが男の世界になったら日本よに
なるでちゃんと評価すればええんだダメな
やつはダメと言えばええところがいいやつ
はいいと言わないか全然言わんわな大谷
ぐらいのもんが褒められるのはね大谷を
産んだのも1番最初のもじゃないのもから
始まってねでのもが大リーグに行くって
言った時のあのマスコミの態度はないや
行ったってダメだって言っとってあんな
もんつよせ言ってところが向こうで大活躍
したじゃんいもう何も言わんわねで太谷は
なぜあんだけ褒めるかと言うとあれで
儲かる
日本一を決めるな日本シリーズをやっとる
時にアメリカの野球の報道しするじゃん
総裁戦もそうやったろ総裁戦をやっとる時
に大統領戦の構造の方が大きいやないか
情けなと思わんかあいつら愛国心が
ないコメント欄で戸塚校長の指示政党は
何かとか政治についてどう思ってるの
かって質問が結構あったんで伺いたいです
俺はね保守維新でもいいし自民党でもええ
ともかく補習が正しい野党はみんな間違っ
た哲学やリベラルみたいな精神論でやれば
間違いに決まっとるじゃん精神の定義は
行動のプログラムだそのためにあるんで
あって何も神聖なものとかな尊厳がどう
のこうのそんなもんやないよ具体的なもん
ないだから授業でも仏教でも精神論が
ものすごく具体的やないだから科学になっ
とるんよね実際に行動面から精神を逆に
見とる仏教なんてねようこんなこと
考えつくなと思うぐらい考えついたんや
自分が実際にやってみてそう感じたんだ
考えることは間違っとっても感じることは
まず正しいんよ理性が正しいというところ
に1番間違いがあってねで日本は理性が
正しいじゃない本能が正しいというずっと
それでやってきた国なんだからそいつを
いきなり理性が正しいに変えちまってで今
その血管が出とるんよね政党的には
リベラルと保守の政党で保守だったら何で
もいいかなっていう感じたうんもう本当の
星やったらねだけど今見たら自民党の中に
リベラルがおるやろあんも信用したらいか
んわな自民党とリベラルが一緒になれる
わけやないだけど自民党の議員がリベラル
やっとる特に若手はねあんなものは当選さ
せたらいかんわさ石さんとかは結構左よ
りって言われたりすると思うん
です石さんようわからんね今までそう活躍
戦やったからね今からどういうことやるの
か見取らんとしょうがないわねあの人の
目つき悪いねこうやって救いあげるような
目で見るからいかんのやしかもこう
まっすぐやなしにこうなってなでこうやっ
とるんやあいつはちょっとなあ校長の嫌い
な政治家結構思い浮かぶんですけどこの
政治家は認めてるみたいな人ってたりする
んです
かあの時石葉さんよりも高一さんの方が
ええと思ったあの人堂々と保守をやるやろ
男はダメよねマスコミ気にするもんで
マスコミの言うことを聞いたふりをするわ
ねだけど高石さんは真っこからマスコミ
あれするじゃんあれはいいと思うな歴代
だったどうですか安倍さんはええわね吉田
茂は良かったわね吉田茂さんが総理大臣の
時って戦後すぐじゃん長が20代とかうん
であの人はと引き換えに経済発展を取った
わねでおかげで経済発展したじゃんで日本
も守れた安保のおかげでねあの時の学生
運動というのは安保反対でね日本が初めて
革命が起こるかっていうぐらいの騒ぎに
なったわさ安保のおかげでこんな風に慣れ
たのにその安保にするいうのは悪い奴らよ
ねなんで安保に反対したんやロシアに不利
だからてい奴らはアメリカよりロシアと
一緒になりたい共産主義やからねだけど今
のロシア見たらなんでよかったと思うやろ
共産主義国はみんなダメよねで日本はそれ
を免れたんだけどリベラルのおかげで
リベラル独裁になっちまっとるじゃん今
えっとね私の言うことは正しいこと
ばっかりだだから今からまだ続くからえ
人生死ぬ時に満足の行く人生それを送り
たけれ
ばチャンネル登録してずっと聞いてくれ